ich habe heute die freiheiten jedes
europäische land zu gehen und alles zu
sagen aber ich kann in meinem eigenen
land nicht noch transnistrien um über
das zu schreiben was dort passiert
republik moldau
behörden der separatisten gebiet
transnistrien melden mehrere angriffe
auf infrastruktur in ihrer region
die journalistin alina die macht sich
regelmäßig ein bild von der lage an der
grenze zu dem abtrünnigen gebiet
[Musik]
max wie dieser situation macht den
menschen angst sie müssen jeden tag aufs
neue schauen wie es weitergeht
der erste plan ist glücklich in der
eigenen heimat zu leben
aber der zweite plan ist wie kann man
schnell fliehen wenn ein krieg
ausbrechen
auf die andere seite des mister nach
transnistrien fährt die journalistin
ungarn
ich habe mein eigenes trauma
1994 wollte ich dort eine reportage
machen und wurde verhaftet einen tag
lang wurde ich dort festgehalten und
meine kamera wurde mir weggenommen
die republik moldau wird unabhängig die
mehrheitlich russische bevölkerung in
der region transnistrien will da nicht
dazu gehören
im krieg um ihre unabhängigkeit kommen
den transnistrischen separatisten
russische truppen zu hilfe
seitdem existiert in der republik moldau
der de facto staat transnistrien
der konflikt eingefroren doch die
russischen soldaten sind in
transnistrien geblieben und auch im rest
moldaus moskau weiterhin kontrolle
wir hatten nie die volle kontrolle über
unser land
die kontrolle hatten wir nur in unseren
köpfen
tatsächlich ist es so dass russland
einen teil des moldauischen territoriums
kontrolliert aber auch einen teil der
moldauischen politiker unserer wahlen
und unserer medien
russische provokationen gestoppte
energielieferungen und mächtige
oligarchen verhindern fortschritt im
land
[Musik]
alina radio ist mitgründerin der
wochenzeitung sie wurde gerade darin
moldaus hauptstadt chisinau mit ihren
investigativen recherchen versucht sie
korruption im land aufzudecken
seit beginn der russischen invasion im
nachbarland arbeiten die reporter innen
im schichtsystem
seither zeigt sich ihnen der riss in der
gesellschaft wieder deutlich
die politiker haben von anfang an nichts
unternommen um die gesellschaft zu einem
irgendwann begannen die menschen in der
neuen landessprache rumänisch über ihre
traumata zu sprechen und wir haben große
traumata aus der zeit der sowjetunion da
habe ich bemerkt dass wir die
russischsprachige bevölkerung verlieren
und diese sich nur noch aus moskau
informiert
jetzt hat die regierung in moldau einig
gesetze verabschiedet russische medien
und symbole wurden verboten doch das
kann die jahrzehntelange russische
propaganda nicht wettmachen
[Musik]
molde aus hauptstadt chisinau
zwischen modernem europa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und sowjetischem relikt
zerrissen zwischen aufbruch und alten
machtansprüche
in chisinau schaut man besorgt auf
moskaus expansionspläne
kürzlich verkündete der russische
general major agus der mineralien
die kontrolle über den süden der ukraine
ist ein weiterer weg nach transnistrien
wo es ebenfalls beweise für die
unterdrückung der russischsprachigen
bevölkerung gibt
unruhen provozieren lügen verbreiten
spaltung vorantreiben jahrelange
russische praxis in der republik moldau
ähnlich wie in der ukraine
transnistrien als moldauischer don was
die menschen in transnistrien sehen die
europäischen standards
der moldauische don was ist in gewisser
weise europäisiert
die menschen dort verstehen dass
russland sie unterstützt aber sie
verstehen auch dass die europäische
union groß und reich ist und einen hohen
lebensstandard hat
aline radu und ihre kolleginnen setzen
am tag der pressefreiheit ein zeichen
gegen russische propaganda
vor der russischen botschaft
angesichts des krieges im nachbarland
scheinen viele moldauer innen zu
begreifen dass sich das land stärker von
russland abgrenzen muss
ja der krieg ist eine schlimme sache
aber er weist uns in moldau den
richtigen weg